hello rejects hello reject Greg here
John here we're gonna talk about Ben
Affleck's the Batman Batman also how
it's announced the villain the official
villain will be Deathstroke let's let's
kick this off let's kick this off movie
talk comment Asha that the Batman that's
a cool title I think it's a really cool
title very simple easy to hold on to I
like it better than Batman I don't get
how you really do a video about the
[ __ ] title honestly before doing a
movie the character and it is uh I made
a huge deal like the Batman is a cool
sounding two words but you know we we
add the and the main idea of the movie
2012 that isn't the new predator movie
called the Predators yeah I don't know
this will be the all defining Batman
film with that that title kind of holds
a mantle to kind of have that I eat
diese finding a bad man yeah that's our
talk about the time Deathstroke though
as the villain I believe Joe mangala ha
mohali is supposed to be playing what's
the guy's name Meagan Meagan man Geum
angle Dorne mangled orange guy whose
penis you see and Magic Mike I loved him
in true blood my least favorite actor
and true blood but Flash Thompson
Deathstroke as the villain though i
think is a great choice and a lot of
people have been asking you know Kennedy
the Joker's gonna be j.lo those Joker
there he's gonna be black mass know it's
gonna be death stroke and death stroke I
know he's got in like interpretations of
the batman games he's more part of
Nightwing's row gallery than he is
Batman's name though he is a Batman
villain as well but tasted DC but he's a
DC overall villains a mercenary he has
you know superhuman abilities but he's
not to superhuman to the point where
yeah it takes away humanity from him
because he has really high intellect you
know you can't think like nine times
faster than the average human being yeah
he doesn't have like a magic power yeah
like all of his senses are enhanced he's
stronger faster we can recover faster it
too but I think overall though he is a
great opponent for to call this film the
Batman and to define who is Batman in
terms of Batman
skills I think Deathstroke is a perfect
counterpart to that there's also a
really trained highly skilled fighter
like that like Batman and that's his
main forte but he also kills
relentlessly if he has to he's known to
commit massacres and whatnot Deathstroke
he can kind of switch between his moral
codes is code of honor what I don't know
if Ben Affleck is gonna address the fact
that Abby vs you know he was you know
killing people in the film a big part of
that man what we've known from the
interpretations Batman doesn't kill
that's a big part of his moral code is
to not do that Deathstroke that's not
really part of his coat he killed we
know whatever he feels like he should
kill or when he has to kill oh yeah and
that's what can make this movie
interesting it seems like to me is
you're gonna have two guys the very
conflicting ideologies a decent match up
in terms of abilities yeah because
Deathstroke is kind of a lone warrior he
doesn't really conform to good or evil
side he's kind of just a standalone dude
who occasionally takes the bad side and
occasionally taste a good side even
depending on where he's a penguin
depending on where he is in life and
like one interpretation I saw was him an
arrow which was a cool interpretation
that was more about before he became you
know like the really defined Deathstroke
mercenary in the streets of not just
Starling city but all over the DC worlds
you know Gotham and whatnot blüdhaven in
terms of set of skills he's the perfect
opponent towards Batman he's extreme
martial artists he knows how to use
weapons as well Batman mean despite what
some stuff we saw him bbs he doesn't use
guns but Deathstroke really uses his
guns and I think that watching the two
of them fight will be a great thing
because Batman is not superhuman in any
capacity he's super skilled and that's
all through training where his death
stroke he had training but then he also
had enhanced abilities after having
experiments done on it cuz like the
Joker you can't really have a cool fight
scene between Batman and the Joker yes
it's gonna be like a situation the Joker
set up the Batman has to yeah deal with
yeah cuz the Joker's more about getting
the ultimate rise out of that man but in
terms of seeing a villain that Batman
can go toe-to-toe with me I feel like
the dark knight rises try doing that
with bane batman but if you won't really
want to honor the comics being in the
comics as a wrestle or
recall him having the same kind of
fighting style as Bruce Wayne develop
I'm really hoping that for this one they
have very specific fighting sauce you
see the way that Batman can fight in BBS
now to be cool to see him go toe-to-toe
with someone who could fight similarly
to him yeah yeah you'll have to tactical
critical thinkers with their own
enhanced ability is not even up there
the same but you know that you have a
matchup that makes sense on a level
playing field Bain vs Batman at least in
the context of the Dark Knight Rises
especially is two very different you
know ideologies and fighting styles and
in this it seems like you'll have at
least something similar you know guns
versus gadgets and what not to me
Deathstroke in some ways is what Batman
could have been if he kind of crossed
over a little bit you know who killed
Joe Chill a lot of the times they talked
about the Joker being what Batman could
be turned into but I really think
Deathstroke is more along the lines of a
bama could be because Batman has these
wide variety of martial arts skills
combat skills and that's Deathstroke who
kinda falls too much darker territory I
mean they even had rumors of night we
making an appearance at BBS which he
didn't I'm hoping that this does somehow
linked if they're gonna do there as much
as I want this to be a standalone film
and other producers are gonna step it
and make it connect to some bigger
multiverse the multiverse everything the
11 it's a bigger Cinematic Universe and
I'm hoping that with the use of deaths
rope because he is known more as a
Nightwing villain they do connect that
to him like I don't know if he lives and
go to blood hated appreciative and Joe
manglehorn five years can't get his name
registre fuse to even learn in the films
I've seen him in and in the work of true
blood I've seen every episode true blood
the guy definitely has a good body type
we all know that as hell he can have
like the cool serious there but it
serves of his acting abilities I'm not
sure if he's really the guy I would've
first imagined to be Deathstroke because
I don't have it enough strong faith in
his dramatic acting abilities to truly
believe this I don't know Ben Affleck's
a great director he's an he's not just a
great filmmaker but he's also an actress
director so he knows how to bring great
performed and have all been obvious
movies the number one thing he does is
make another actor look better than him
like he tends to do that yeah then gives
me some faith in this and get why people
like Joe Manganiello is a charming
charismatic guy yeah definitely but you
know I don't think I've seen a
performance yet row like that use some
chops you know I think Ben Affleck good
buddy it would be a great director for
him to work with for this especially
yeah and in the comics of death stroke
he had a wife at one point and he has a
son too I don't know if it's all gonna
be included in the film I don't know if
they're gonna include his whole
backstory in one arms name is Martha
yeah it's not fighting you know I hope
that the film does provide a complexity
there to you know one of the great
things from the Dark Knight trilogy was
having counterpart villains at Challenge
Bruce Wayne's point of views towards
life his ideologies and whatnot exactly
and I really hope the Deathstroke as I'd
see because destro he's kind of like
in-between of all ideologies he doesn't
have a very specific point of view
towards things it's all very kind of
circumstantial for Deathstroke I'll
where he's going to lean to at the end
of the day he's mainly just a survivor
and you know like he's a contract killer
wolf he's out from self yeah exactly so
it'll be interesting to see why he
becomes the main villain in this story
it would be cool if this Batman movie
would be the first r-rated solo Batman
film highly doubt that's gonna happen it
would be cool though if they did cuz
destro can be a very violent villain I
feel like like to true if you have a
villain who uses weapons like I feel
like you kind of have to I mean I know
Deadpool was inspired by Deathstroke i
ain'ta they're very similar characters
except for the whole like comedic
element of it but Deadpool r-rated and
it needed the are waiting for it to
really work and I feel like to
capitalize off Deathstroke's abilities
for someone who could go on killing
massacres with his bullets and [ __ ] I
really feel like yeah it would be much
more effective and you'd have a much
more terrifying villain and someone
who's really enrage Batman there was
even one person then I totally think
that making it our rating worked out
that DC is gonna go that route however I
you know it's weird I feel like if they
made it our rate I feeling people will
tune in at the same time Deathstroke's
not as popular of a
as other row gallery villains of Batman
yeah I mean he's not the the obvious
choice but that could be cool it's a
basic way to phrase this but it's all in
how they handle it I they take advantage
of the matchup of these two characters
in all that they are and not just you
know oh how are they gonna fight yeah
you look back at a lot of different
action movies and stuff you know I'm not
saying that everything needs to be radar
by any stretch but if you have a villain
like that it seems like to truly make
them villainous to understand the
consequences why we need this guy off
the street why Batman is to fight this
guy we need to be able to see the
repercussions of his actions and violent
horror that Deathstroke can infuse is a
very significant part to what makes him
he used to be called Deathstroke the
Terminator and some people so call him
that we got to be afraid of a villain
that's part of the trouble with a lot of
these movies is like we're not really
afraid of the threat because we know
that our hero eventually we'll have it
covered that's a place I feel like for
this in our rating you know could help
that because that can make Deathstroke
truly seemed villainous but overall I do
think it's a great choice for death star
to be the villain because you take away
the superhuman abilities he's still a
very skilled tactical warrior just like
Bruce Wayne is now he has a superhuman
abilities and I'm sure that'll be
included in the film origins origins
yeah having those two go toe-to-toe it
would be the first batman film where I
feel like we're getting to Barry's like
I know bein is a similar fighter in the
dark knight rises and he was from the
League of Shadows as well so that's why
he had this is similar fighting style
but this would be a really well
justified reason to see them go
toe-to-toe cuz Batman has his his
weapons his gadgets a stroke as his as
well I'm really excited to see cuz I
feel like this will be the first time
that Ben Affleck really amps up his
action directing yeah and I'm really I'm
really looking forward to seeing that
because there's some great action in the
town live by night or live by nine looks
like there's gonna have some cool action
sequences but that man's a full-on
tactical martial artist and I'm really
excited to see what Ben Affleck does
with directing action scenes such as
that I'm the engine like to like I do
hope that they they bring in that
Detective vibe as well you know they are
critical thinking and the reflex is the
mental processing so we want to think
about Deathstroke is that his intellect
is incredibly high it's part of his
superhuman a bill
is how a guy isn't it like this so it
would kind of suck if they don't have
that well yeah if that just is only
happiness yeah that's right yeah the
world's greatest detective going up
against a highly intellectual
supervillain who also has a wide variety
of like combat skills as well yeah as
opposed to just going up against
intellect yeah so let's let's see both
in equal measure alright guys you're new
to the channel if you're new to the
channel subscribe today become a rat jon
is the son of me nothing here
facebook.com slash the yes and boom pots
go check out those pages there and shout
out to Matt Damon hey Matt when are you
gonna get in a superhero we're gonna get
a superhero movie fan decks time I think
Matt Damon would be a great great
villain as Catalan mmm sure in cab woman
in the next Ben Affleck film yeah yeah
want to have a kid no I want Matt Damon
be poison I don't want to be a gay
relationship I want him to play a lady I
think Matt Damon has enough range you
saw it in the latest Bourne film like he
can do that that's a terrible